[Musique]
une carte réactualisé deux fois par jour
disponible sur internet et diffusé par
les médias
cette carte donnera donc une information
fonctionner suivant ses couleurs si le
risque météo existe pas s'il existe nous
aurons donc la couleur orange qui
apparaîtra aussi le rouge et un bulletin
de suivi commentaires permettant de
préciser le type de risque météo france
affiche ainsi son dispositif d' alerte à
destination du grand public
une leçon tirée des crues de l'aude à
novembre 99 et les tempêtes de vent en
décembre de la même année
les informations diffusées avait été
juste scientifiquement n'est pas très
parlante pour les gens météo france se
veut maintenant développer la culture du
risque chez les citoyennes
[Musique]